hey Mike do you remember used to invite
us to your house to see you Tigers yeah
don't worry about the cat
hold on this is one thing don't turn
your back on it he tells us this like it
was actually too late at that point all
right another epic episode we have very
special very very special person here
you know me we can call him anything
didn't call him um
the designer to the end the city of love
though you can't even came down for me
wouldn't you first start well anyway it
was the one and only call canal a car
right what was the first thing you ever
made you know it's funny
talked about the other day one of my
first suits that I made we sold to
Simon's and do you remember that I saw
you at Jackie to fit you you ejected he
was the first celebrity I saw from the
hood wearing my stuff that he bought at
Simon's he had no idea was me I told
Jackie please introduce me to Mike he
got my clothes on and he she introduced
me to him and that was what one of the
first guys that helped set it off and
show the people on the streets who we
were this is back in 1990 that's so
awesome
damn 1990 huh yeah this was real
listen that was that was just what it
was them and what made you think that
what did you say that did you say um we
should make our own clothes for our own
community well how did this come about
making clothes yeah
well basically you know my family's from
I was born in Costa Rica my dad's
Panamanian when I moved to the States
I was like three years old and my dad
used to get his clothes made by a tailor
so my dad just called Lancie Street buys
fabric and go back to Flatbush he's go
back to Flatbush and have his Haitian
till and make his clothes for him sorry
I used to see the process of how you
could make cold and what I don't really
know how to sew so
the hood how it is everybody respects
you based upon what you wearing yeah you
know I mean if you come outside your
closes you closes whack and get disks so
I remember moving into the projects in
East New York from Flatbush and I went
outside trying to meet all the kids I
was 12 years old
I'm excited thinking about the plain
dirt stickers you got on there
days like minutes just skips man your
mother bought this from the grocery
store Matthew [ __ ] out he was [ __ ] so I
went home crying to my mother your mom I
need some money buy some clothing these
kids it's making fun of my clothing you
know my mother from the island she's
like boy I gotta find yourself a job
somewhere close you get one pair of
sneakers for the year you good so I
refuse to go back out there hang out
with them I find me a newspaper route
he's gonna fire 13 more and deliver
newspapers I'll get money just to buy
clothing and that's what was my first
take and to realize how important
fashion was to the kids in inner-city
big wow yeah it means everything
yeah means everything your would you
status what you wearing that's your
that's your vehicle that's your car at
the time so what happened from there was
me and all my friends used to out try to
out shop each other and try to get the
fresh cold and then we found something
fresh we never told each other what we
got it from right so I thought about my
dad till one day as I damn I make it out
for distilling none of these dudes have
it yeah I did yeah yeah yeah so when I
wore the outfit around aways but you
know back in the 90s a boy was hustling
so there's a lot of money on the street
I have money
so now whatever on a bus ago would you
get the food you get a phone sorry I
ain't about to tell her what my tail is
like if you want when I make you one so
Lydia I started making cold and boil the
hustlers in the projects he's to give me
quasi cash I started making him outfits
and really that's how Street where it
really started
there's nobody could ever say they
started Street right before me because
we even know we was doing we was just
hustling we just took our street hustle
and turn it to Colvin that's all it was
so when did you make the move out to LA
yeah that's really important what
happened was a lot of my friends started
getting locked up and killed in the
projects from hustling VanDerveer
East our city starts to birth
right question linden project yeah yes
yeah right the end right right by the
Bell Parkway one day was just sitting in
the park that thing I'm a to train out
there yes / - exactly train Pennsylvania
and on I sit in the park one day and
he's just just do walk by it one of my
outfits on and I was bragging to these
girls saying I made that outfit for him
days I know you didn't I said he'll come
over so Duke comes over his name was
Jody says who made that jacket for you
he's that called me - why what's up
she's like let me see a jacket she's
looking at the jacket he's like yeah
with Carl made how come his name ain't
on it then and that's when it hit me I
should stop putting my name on the
clothing I wasn't putting any name in
the corner I was just making custom-made
quoting no name on it you know I'm
saying so when she said that I started
thinking like damn I want to be like
Ralph Lauren
I wanna be like Tommy he'll think I'm
gonna be like Calvin Klein so I went
home and started come up with a name my
family's last name was Williams at the
time my father changed to an American
last names like Carl Williams jeans just
didn't have a good ring to it
Kenai was a question he's asked myself
all the time kind of successful kind of
come from the streets and really build
the brands to be worldwide known I
didn't know the answer to that question
but I knew if I put that part of my name
after answer that question every day yes
I can that's how Karl Kani came about
and I moved to California in 89 my
friend named AZ on a project who you
know AZ caught a case he's supposed to
do five years in jail a Z skip town
world Orange County living his brother
Orange County so we lost contact him out
he caught me when they see your car what
you do understand him hustling these
clothes out he said you should come to
LA men got this new rap cooper hit he's
hot
he sent me a eazy-e CD in the mail a
cassette in the mail and I was like this
is bumpin so easy fathers storm Crenshaw
Boulevard
43:12 Crenshaw we open up shop right
there and that's really how it all
started June 23rd 1989 yeah Abby left
New York came out here so we could be
more focused just on the business no
distractions that's amazing yeah
straight up but you've your company
you've been through some serious crises
with your business and and everything
that has happened on your journey with
that tell us a little bit about that
you know cuz we started from the bottom
so he came out the other brother named
carl carl jones from croscill yeah we
became partners yeah we came out here we
only had a thousand dollars in a pocket
full of dreams but the key was we had
that New York hustle in that New York
costume you come from Brooklyn may
discussing about you losing is not an
option so he came out here he's hustling
on Crenshaw some gangbangers came in our
store robbers at gunpoint took our
sewing machine all our samples so we
can't we had two choices that point easy
to go back to New York what I tell them
between our legs or we're gonna find
another way to hustle sweet I don't get
an apartment in Hollywood start doing a
mail-order business out the apartment in
Hollywood one night a Z was out to the
club's he told me you'll come outside
man
come to the club cross was having a
fashion show we got to meet this dude we
go out there cross clothes another black
owned company they have financing behind
them and we met and within 20 minutes
Carl Jones is like yo I heard about your
stuff if you want come partners I'll you
want to help you out and my heart just
started beating really fast you know
where we from like nobody just help you
I'll just help you out one do you know
saying I am buddies wondering what does
it do about the still on my [ __ ] you
know I'm saying so I went home and told
my mom she's like you need to pray about
this how you feel I just went for it we
came partners came 50/50 partners in the
first month together we did like four
million dollars in sales over one store
there was history ever since the first
year we did like 89 million this is back
in 1990 us together so tell me now what
do you do to compete with um the
competition of clothes now how do you
become so um creative to deal with the
clothes of the 2000 yeah I think you
gotta learn how to adjust with the
moment and just with the time and don't
become on those designers that stuck on
the past because you got what are you
wearing now yeah I say to myself what do
I wear I don't win then I went to
clothes I wore 20 years ago yeah what's
old is new it's all coming back with a
closer more 20 years old clothes I the
clothes I wear now two clothes I wore
when I was fighting like really I'm what
you spoke to old school that used to
wear back in the days for you
[ __ ] bro the law points oh my god the
back we've been calling it in we're like
we got to get Mike a new tracksuit
vintage old-school vintage rate so you
just asked me how do we adjust today
what we do we do unique collaborations
like right now we just did a
collaboration with this company called
pretty little thing it's a fast fashion
woman's company they do about six
hundred million the reason why they
wanted to do a collaboration with us
it's pretty little thing wanted to get
validated on a street where market and
Karl Kani we wanted more of that
crossover market with our brand so he's
able to combine two brands together we
both got what we needed out to
collaboration so just doing unique
marking in very much social media like
your like back in the day is all about
source and vibe magazine that don't mean
nothing no more it's all about social
media influences and you know things
like that so change the game right now
that's interesting it's interesting how
that's happening yeah not nobody just
look at magazine the magazines your
phone no you know these magazines
anymore absolutely right it's all about
influences yeah and you put in a phone
booth get the whole history of it yeah
do you do you see with the influencer
marketing do you see the returns of that
you would see in the past with say
tradition traditional marketing style
you know the funny thing about marketing
you gotta kind of have like a gambler's
mentality in this business you've gotta
got to put it out there don't think
about it maybe the mini start thinking
you're gonna overthink but [ __ ] you know
just got to do it and once your business
is going he's gonna keep going and going
don't think once you start thinking you
may [ __ ] around a stop cuz you look
crazy wait you number from back in the
day man yeah
do you transform your whole body I
didn't tell you I did that I hated a
competition really and I knew I knew
that this thing was gonna be a marathon
not a sprint
yeah I'm say so I knew I had to add to
outlast them you know saying that's our
last time cuz I knew a lot of them
didn't get in the game
for the [ __ ] guts to be in desire to
get for the money and I know with that
they're gonna leave that alone
this is a tough business you ain't gonna
like it when it goes down we say the
marathon is a war
I said marathon or originated from the
water war marathon I'm in grief you know
me fighting with the Persians and stuff
and that's the guy that he ran 26 and a
half miles from there and had a heart
attack he delivered the message and drop
dead of a heart attack so ever since
then they meet that marathon yeah from
the war marathon Wow
so that last time Mike yeah you have to
yeah yes in my life except from this I
just had problems from when I was going
crazy and all that [ __ ] back in back in
90s and 96 I said what was happening in
my life it was just I had our last
people people in federal agencies a
certain television company the papers
they wouldn't deal with me certain
people from certain soda company the TV
company wouldn't deal with me and I
thought that people you started dying
him like my life started changing you
know me but you gotta wake tomorrow and
why are you waiting them out just
suffering hey Mike do you remember used
to invite us to your house to see your
Tigers yeah don't worry about the cat
don't worry we'll be like hold on this
is one thing don't turn your back on it
what he tells us this like it was
actually too late at that point
Mike hey man what you guys have come
over my house with dinner who they might
gonna come he's a hand make sure you
guys come up get dinner prepared for you
to go there Mike we're covered man we
covered these two fight the whole crew
to his crew was cool
that was where were the Tigers kept in
his garage you kept them in your garage
yeah okay two of them yeah yeah more
than one that's a sure Karl so that
first time you went and met Mike you got
introduced to Mike how did that some
people that died that nobody people got
trampled in staircase yeah it was
crowded
I think Diddy and Heavy D was doing a
big event Heavy D yeah they've done a
big event there yeah was your question
when you guys first met yeah what was
that like man it was that was Brooklyn
right there man that's Mike Tyson I mean
I used to think about Mike Mike he's
inspiring me I used to like think about
him on a treadmill just think about his
grind like how he used to do it you know
Santa's helped me in a : business and
that's what really inspired me him and
just certain rap records you just think
about this yeah yeah motivation but over
and over like a billion times in my
[ __ ] that playing it over yeah yeah
yeah the tape thing had waited with a
rewind then game play
that's that Brooklyn [ __ ] man it's like
yeah where we this is hard to explain
when you come up from there you just
experience so many things at such a
young age just becomes a part of who you
are so about proving something yeah all
the time
even when we went shopping is one thing
we get the money to go shop and guess
what the problem was we have to worry
about not getting robbed coming back
home with the clothes that was the drama
because the robber the waitingwaiting
friend mr. Depp say hang out smoking
children from the spill you hope that
that's some way it's cool no I don't
know get him
yeah get him get him and that's what we
dealt with on a daily basis yeah we to
all those um what would those guys call
over the shower path in here I'm cutting
them dumb guys we only have to worry
about those guys in VanDerveer and stuff
you know we all knew glaze and Tata
knows
yeah yeah I can see that let me now
how's he doing
that is good damn good that's crazy
about Lou no one's beautiful till he
called me yesterday that was a good dude
I was a good teammate there Lou still
live in Brooklyn yeah he told me tell
you hi yeah lose some time though yeah
he's a good man it's been time since
like early 90s and [ __ ] but 25 years
yeah just my two homies doll you know so
we all kind of like knew the same people
yeah you're saying kind of built from
the same cloth yeah and you know just
crossed paths all the time yeah
absolutely not and everybody going
through all that and then to find
yourselves having success and you know
like mine you got deal with the oldest
legend yeah worry about but you gotta
protect me unless I am 50 I know how do
you protect it I mean you hate to say
you think yeah police police they're not
gonna protect you you have to get your
own enforces that's crazy right yeah the
police are not gonna protect you yeah
the taxpayer
you know I own the street robbing
stealing them they can't protect you you
have to get your own enforces now so now
that's fitting that's stepping the line
of law enforcement pretty much yeah it's
interesting like you're talking about
having bodyguards no absolutely the
people that you yeah it's interesting
man listen you think once we got one of
these thugs company and things happen
the way we anticipate the man you think
we're gonna leave an open door like that
come on really
I thought you can't do you justice yes
you set yourself up for failure
yeah what ID tags Mike you last week I
need my guardian morning juice that
sounds like your problem there I don't
care go rob a bank okay put some money
down and win like a man
the matter with you don't even listen to
that [ __ ] man go online right
now my bookie online [ __ ] it
yeah hooked him under New Year's my
bookie online I think that boosted from
them
that's right my bookie online you play
you win they pay that's what I'm talking
about good all day every day
let's do it my bookie online whoa my
bookie online has better bonuses and
more prop bets than any other sports
book period sign up for a chance to
receive $1,000 bonus at my bookie online
today
that's my bookie my B oh okay ie and
don't forget to use the promo code
hotboxing to activate the offer it was a
beautiful to hear you talk about how you
came to understanding how important
fashion was but it's something we talk
about here all the time do you feel like
there's something inside of you that
inspires you on your mission through
life like from the time you were a
little kid was there you know a voice
within you that you know was pushing you
urging you on to this path yeah I think
so I felt like I always want to do
better my father he came to United
States opened up his own business within
a year they sent for me my mother my
sister he always strapped joel fancy
cars Cadillacs he hung out at this
little bar on Utica called salt and
pepper but he always one of the best
things he left my mom's and my sister
and left us in the projects and I was 12
years old just left
Easter yeah he just left us and moved
with some other woman down in Florida
and I think I was the best thing ever
happened in my life because with him
there I couldn't be a man no second I
couldn't grow to be who I was he'll be
too controlling
I'm saying so without her near my
motherless let me do what I had to do so
I ran the streets to do that to do but
the key was my mother kept me in
Catholic school even though we live in
the project she worked hard to keep me
my sister in Catholic school for a year
so I was able to see things slightly
different to everybody else that I grew
up with I was able to hang out with
white kids Chinese kids Indian kids
there saw life a little bit differently
hung out with them
so I strive to the yearn to be
successful came from my mom she was a
registered nurse for 18 years Brooklyn
Jewish Hospital worked the night shift
just to send me my sister to school so I
had to make it and she gave me a choice
when I graduated high school she said
eating we'll go to college and get a job
you're not gonna stay home and that's
what made me take the clothing thing
serious to come out to LA you start to
make this thing happen and then in terms
of business and I look at things I'd be
like the little things we go through and
business happen to deal with another
company or deal with the manufacturer
that's nothing compared to what you got
deal with in the streets so if you can't
figure this one out something's wrong
something's wrong and nothing's giving
it to us every day we wake up on the
saying grind every day all day because
it's fun so mental once you went you in
from Brooklyn you know the young kid
hustle in the street if it comes with
time you come to an eighth you say I
want to get out of here I don't want to
live here no more I don't want to raise
my kids here can't you see you seeing
Toby said well black people could live
place to go [ __ ] green card to
do it like a snatch your chain I put a
gun in your face when you with your wife
and your kids you know you know the way
about somebody killing your kids tonight
when you hear the gunfire is that my kid
looking out the door
we got the window we didn't have phones
back then so you don't know if they got
shot or not you don't know you know it's
crazy to like you don't know if you grew
up in Brooklyn you deal with this
everyday you don't know it any other
light but that until you move somewhere
else and see a life it could be
different
otherwise you think that is just your
reality for everybody especially
nowadays they have social medias now
people could see back in days we had
none of that
yeah the only thing you saw is what you
saw I was looking I look at I Love You
Tube that's on YouTube I can go
Brownsville hoods
and I can look at the browser and see
all my neighborhood to see and I see
people having interviews about yes
Browns are disgusting it's not bad they
when I move oddity and how many killings
and robberies and everything and rapes
and everything happened
and I mean saying I'm looking at people
this is my neighborhood I see these
people animals and this and then how
they eating the cops always [ __ ]
abusing and fighting with net dropping
[ __ ] from 20 foot story project they
told I'm [ __ ] stoves and fridges on
top cops heads and cars and [ __ ] this is
crate you know yeah it's [ __ ] crazy
man so I'm saying to myself I'm looking
this is my neighbor and still is the
crater guy I want to be there so bad I
can't be there I'm some stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] happen but I want to be there so
bad I said feeling energy yeah and never
do it again and I have to kill a
[ __ ] quick mm-hmm why do you
want to be there much because that's who
I am
but I'm not that way anymore but still
Who I am and I want to understand why
was that that was can i I want to
observe that I want to see me before you
know I mean not I'm not meaning I want
to see that person gonna be my kids I
want my kids to talk to that person you
know that's your father
without a big fancy name a big fancy
clothes and cars that's your father
right there you're afraid of him that's
your father I see be free say hi to him
my kids like [ __ ] I want to talk to
him
you know I said Minchin be like that's
your father that's just hurtful to your
father I want to talk to him either
they have no no inclination you know
there's no way they can fathom living
their being from there
yeah people screaming and cursing at
their father and their mother right in
front of their face ain't bad crazy [ __ ]
to them cops beating up your mother your
father in front and you can't do [ __ ]
you know I had my kid my son is 22 and I
charted some stories about how we grew
up
okay sometimes I wish I could just drop
him off in the projects for a month yeah
there you can told me off the roof that
okay dad thank you I'm gonna thrown off
the roof dad yeah and then you shoot me
for no reason that you have to cuz I'm
from this neighborhood somebody shoot me
can I'm from this neighborhood its
neighbor never did none to that new
highly go to shoot that don't make sense
that they don't get it it's the truth
how do you guys make sense of that it
goes like that I don't know cause
perception is but this is how I go from
my world and Brownsville New York right
this is the real way there's people in
Brownsville you know you be nice to them
there's some people in Brownsville
they have the biggest family and they're
mean and they know that they have the
biggest family and they all have
different personalities even though some
of the family members don't get along if
it's been enough you're getting to fight
the whole [ __ ] buildings coming out
on the side even I don't like I mean I
know he's a no-good [ __ ] so we
know be nice to this family be nice and
avoid people who can crush you and try
to be cool with them just like we live
now with corporations don't get this
corporation mad at you be nice with them
don't [ __ ] with the [ __ ] Rockefellers
be nice to the Rothschild that kind of
stuff you know me it's the same way in
and they're the same way it would be
nice to this family be nice to these
guys sometimes when these [ __ ] gonna
take a [ __ ] they got to give it up to
him take a loss okay
they will [ __ ] you and hope they start
to like you cuz sometimes it's crazy
sometimes this got me robbed me all the
time and then somebody else's loved me
and he takes up for you he likes you you
don't know how these [ __ ] think
you don't know if this guy's gonna kill
you today I gonna kill somebody for you
today it's just crazy man you told my
dealing with some people who are a real
psychopath and that cool with you you
hang out with them everyday but they are
[ __ ] what they can do to another human
being it's just unfuckin fathomable
yeah that's where we come from you know
when all these guys come out of jail
from doing these 25 years these 30 years
a [ __ ] man they sent them right to
our neighbor they don't send them no
[ __ ] listen
you think we do you think we're not
scared of them let's get into we don't
want them in our [ __ ] community but
we're too afraid to tell them to get the
[ __ ] out you gotta savage and vicious
and mean people mind there's no option
it's got deal with it yeah you asking us
how the perception is it's like we know
how to be nice to people but I couldn't
know how to be real nice to people
we went to terrorize a lot you know own
community know how to be nice to people
we don't want to get [ __ ] up
[Music]
we don't wanna be [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
away we don't want to go back that's the
main thing you lose the fight you lose
your money the first name I gotta go
back to Brownsville I go back and living
the [ __ ] project after all this major
success that I gotta go back in that
[ __ ] pride they're gonna open that
[ __ ] door come on that courtyard see
these [ __ ] [ __ ] apartment
soon as you getting around what the [ __ ]
you got whatever [ __ ] you got [ __ ] give
me your tattoos [ __ ] your
[ __ ] skin you you know I'm serious
I'm making fun of us together I remember
dude just to rob you for your gold teeth
oh yeah you got a gold tooth they'll
punch the shot your mouth yeah - can you
fit a mob leader figure out how you're
sneaking I remember them taking my
sneakers listen you're so [ __ ] filled
filled with fear you came and even if
the thought of fighting back the demon
pack goes through your mind you feel
like a [ __ ] sheep in [ __ ] hell are
you so [ __ ] afraid man yeah you know
I mean and then next thing you know you
mix you meet meet a guy right in school
of somebody's a normal guy he's like
he's a nice guy but his brothers one of
those guys so now you're a cool guy you
start hanging with the [ __ ] with his
brother and he's come to rob people his
brother I did but I see you normally
robbery hey let him go he's my brother
him my brother hangs out then he still
haven't eaten then you come like become
like dumb now you're the bully hmm and
that's high cuz you were except to them
yeah well Carl I was born in New York
City too and I left out Brooklyn Park
Slope I went to school day off a little
bit
PS 107 I went to John Jay amazing on 7th
Ave yeah yeah but I remember as a little
kid seeing the sneakers thrown up on the
electrical wires
yeah and I was so ominous and scary to
me as a little kid seeing that because I
didn't know what that meant it looked
like somebody it means am I getting new
pair sneakers is that all it means
I used to scare me I used to think no
somebody's gonna diss you and take your
sneakers right make you bet your day
miserable right or that - yeah
definitely like you to mean ass [ __ ]
kids that are a lot of mean kids mean
[ __ ] kids yeah kids are pretty
[ __ ] me and if you keep you continue
to let them push you to actually kill
you
if you let the Lord of the Flies yeah
Carl where do you think we come from
that's interesting huh like when a very
first whenever we come to your very
first ancestor your most ancient
ancestor thousands and thousands of
years of the first man that had you in a
sack the first man that's your foot the
first men having lifted with your blood
your DNA who do I think he is where I
think he comes from sure yeah
have you ever thought about that you
know when I grew up in Brooklyn we got
knowledge itself when I was like 11
years old my name is Nate Wawa Sean got
a lot refri but soon I was a five
percenter French love I should ask to be
yeah so we have to study these lessons
that tells you about the black man and
not essence Supreme Being interesting
and you couldn't come out Silas you knew
your lessons you get [ __ ] [ __ ] as
equality yeah he had explained equality
the origin of equality this is amazing
so I remember the King is he who sits he
who sits on the throne of power and
rules wisely and justly
that's what King meant and each date had
a different mathematics and you had to
say what the date was and what all being
born to and that's in a circle named by
saying I mean it's coming off the
popular as not as not as
should've he's explained it long his
[ __ ] his name it asked me what it
means what how it equates with today's
mathematic you gotta know you got to
know it no you know is that what you
protect if you see view down with the 5%
is you 40 of them coming ahead
you could be protected yeah you
protecting it in all different
neighborhoods of Brooklyn you good mmm
I'm saying ripped off yeah yeah
look be humiliated for my family in
front of my friends our girlfriend yeah
I remember my mom's used to fire my
lessons come on mothers go to Baptist
Church had me in Catholic school and
Here I am with some 5% a Nation of Islam
paperwork
she's a ticket to throw him away she's
father papers building favors away has
to get another copy of it I had to study
it yeah cuz you knew that it would be
beneficial for you absolutely you better
know that yeah that's real so when you
actually supreme be me I think the
Supreme Being is just a spirit man and
we're all being born from that and I do
believe that we originated in Africa hmm
I do believe that I believe all black
people originated in Africa and started
to descend well I don't believe you
don't do that mm-hmm okay
I don't believe that no why tell me so
how do you think we make the different
races well as if everybody came out of
Africa was black in the world should be
black okay first man how do we how do we
how did the color change the race no one
make the race um a geographical location
dictates our race you know means so all
the black people came from a for
everybody laughter cuz dark black right
so we going to Brazil we go to this we
go to Brazil get the big trees a dam
they hide the Sun hid my skin over over
a couple of hundred years or so your
skin is not black no more after um now
your hair is not curling them or could
they have the big the big what's that
big the big tree that blocked the Sun
for
hitting your head so now you know your
hair moist what's that called the he may
come down you don't get no senses he had
drops and I people changed within a man
in two hundred years what's his name
Alexander Dumas family change yeah when
black Asian guy took a Jewish family
from from new monster Oppenheimer that's
only two hundred years now I didn't
imagine the millions of years the people
could um what's the word we talk about
we've if it's from Africa then there was
no everybody this if it's immaculate we
all related then did anybody's related
you all come from Africa and we couldn't
all come from Africa cuz now research if
you look now there's countries that up
that's built on the other countries
that's older than Africa ya know this
country's built under Turkey that's
older than that for nine thousand nine
what nine thousand years old we don't
know who we are you know that's the fact
we don't know who we don't have much
knowledge knowledge is infinite and most
of the knowledge that we know is lies
yeah we only know what we were told we
don't know anything that's definite only
thing we know it's told and what
happened during our time that we could
see is truthful we can't even see tell
her where we came from
I can't even tell you whose the first
and my first my first bloodline they
were saying who's the first guy they had
my behind my bloodline that created me
who is that person what age were time
with their million years ago were the
two million with your billion years ago
how long was he how long was I in
existence my bloodline in existence did
you get started what wonder years ago 20
years ago during five hundred during
slavery how did it come
I did get to this country how did it get
to Africa you know I know we only know
what people tell us and everything we
know is cryptic yeah we're just
indoctrinated from such a young age with
this history that's really totally made
up as far as we know you know you know
what keeps us searching that keeps us
alive because if I have it because if I
have everything
what's my purpose of living I don't want
to live anymore if I were if I have all
the money in the world all the women in
the world or clothes in the world a
drink there were everything that I
needed to stimulate me as a human being
what do I need to live anymore and it
can be stimulated anymore that's all
that's all I have to get this is all
there's no more yeah sure
there's nothing okay boom right right
it's such a dead end
yeah the material the material
dimensions are this all you sure right
okay good married America the house the
money the cars they got the country I
got the world this is all he got for me
that's all boom I'm gone yeah that's
what we do we need to stimulate our
minds what look as long as we stimulate
our mind we could live once we stuffed
in there [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm out of here
yeah yeah Karl have you um you smoked
some weed
have you always had a relationship with
cannabis after I started I smoked we as
a teenager and then I stopped smoking
weed on a can in California in 89 and it
started erotic
yeah then I started smoking weed again
back in like 96 cause of my cousin he's
in it my friend AZ tasted kind of my
house influenced me he's to come in and
get high makes me see that having a good
old time then one day my cousin Tony
says yo Carl why don't you try smokeless
don't we and watch a movie I'm telling
you man a movie look so so much
different to you Matt I trust you not to
tell you that sure enough I smoke some
weed watch the movie and this movie felt
so good it looks so good and I feel as
this late started me back again and then
it just got to the point just helped me
design better yeah yeah creative Wow
yeah very very is this helps me get in a
zone like unimaginable and fast too yeah
I could do shift really fast yeah so
yeah my relationships been pretty
lately you know I can remember like
being a young chemist rising party 171
probably 77 around 11 years old and I
would um and I used to think I was
dressed really good right could I used
to have um I just have Jean suits like
put Lee suits my leaves back in GPS bra
leave suits are used to have um to a ski
suit like I was going skiing
we didn't go ski it was I thought I was
dressing really good young come 11 years
old I'm really good
you know I'm really looking good and
then I go over with these guys found
rutlander Whitney's them these are
mostly Caribbean people yeah and these
guys addressing the book
they got alligator shoes so I want to be
with these guys what they were doing
their main thing was bred by burglaries
they were breaking the house and during
that process when we were breaking the
house and I was just a kid we would get
guns we get [ __ ] money we would get
[ __ ] this was amazing to me you take
the job you were 11
yeah I'm just gonna rip him two i think
with keys they had keys that fit these
people and the way they did they would
take a key in it which there was jamming
rockin somewhere it wasn't even like
teachers were walking these guys are
just masters nothing to learn just in
the Caribbeans where they came from
m16 would get guns the 40 cards we got
where'd you get the gun just in order
for Jewish in the house yeah oh man you
wouldn't get silverware Gold where it
was crazy it was crazy that's crazy what
neighborhoods would you go into you
would go to the Jewish neighbor you go
to the was thinning enable date there
wasn't any Jewish because there were
things were like they always had jobs
yeah it went right to regular American
blacks they weren't late
anybody family's out of the [ __ ]
house oh so you go during the day yeah
early morn when they go to work oh wow
yeah but sometimes um sometimes some
people don't go to working something in
the house where you are when they're
talking to they think you're smarter
came back from school at sea thing in
the house you musta left I don't know
but they were talking good I'm trying to
come a dumb [ __ ] door and I
caught nobody [ __ ] open the door came
to the door and so I open palm to rock
Jan I get in I close the door
[ __ ] [ __ ] one of my friends he was
robbing a chemist our city name shall
eke and the keys that he got it was the
the owner there's a sheriff so he gets
into the crib he starts seeing all these
plaques on the wall right so anyway so
now he's nervous but he's still gonna
Bob the crib now he's looking in there
somebody saw him going to the unit and
call security you know Star City had his
own security call security on him so
security surrounded the apartment so
he's inside the apartment he's calling
all of us we were like twelve years old
you know call security and tell him
something happening your buildings to
take a leave and come to your building
so all my friends we started calling
them by report and [ __ ] another building
of course he
thought they all left of course they
didn't all leave weave when he finally
puts the closest clade comes out because
he had a decision to make if the chef
comes home to see him in the apartment
he crikey shoot his ass so do you give
the stay in the apartment what do you
give yourself up you get the [ __ ] out he
finally thought the coast is clear
came outside me they got him pretty good
pretty classic right there what we do
for clothes and that's all we did it for
clothes alone right that's it none else
yeah good investment none no yeah yeah
it's crazy no well the reason I brought
up the cannabis stuff to Karl is because
that's pretty mind expanding stuff yeah
and mike has had this experience with
the toad do you know about the toad I
don't do you know about DMT and
psychedelics and ayahuasca have you
heard of any of these things I do not
okay so about cheap buttons rivets
thread
you know printing okay that's good stuff
too I mean you know you know what you
know I know about this stuff but DMT is
a molecule five Meo DMT is a molecule
that comes from the Sonoran Desert toad
and you can vaporize this stuff like
smoked it and you have this psychedelic
experience where you experience God you
experience the oneness and the
connectedness of all things you have an
ego death so you experience your whole
life in a matter of seconds and you get
downloaded with as Mike says thousands
of years of information if you don't
even think you want me again
okay but since mike has gone on this
journey and I've been tagging along with
them you know these these topics come up
a lot and it's really interesting when
you start to think about you know where
we come from and why we're here and what
we're all doing here you know because
we're not it's not just all trivial it's
not just all [ __ ] for nothing
you know we're all here for something
you know and I think you do what you do
because you're called to it from a
higher power you know and like Mike and
I doing this show I mean we just create
the space to start having conversations
that really everyone in the world needs
to hear right now
and they don't and excuse me no no
absolutely and that's what I think
sometimes when laughing what do you
think your your purpose here for do you
really think that your purpose is here
the [ __ ] make clothes no somebody
told you that you should make clothes
somebody told me I should bother
I know [ __ ] wonder I want to fight my
[ __ ] and Rob them and [ __ ] you show
people I was tough in the neighborhood
not to [ __ ] buy the box to be
professional be disciplined be focused
on something and the whole world is
empty and only in this matters never in
a million years I couldn't matter the
Majan that right you know and when you
get older you get more focusing you
become more mature and you want to
gather things I might want people to
like you want people to look up to you
won't be respected you want to be liked
you become a different person for that
that's my goal in life to be accepted by
great people if people don't want to
accept me and people that I want to be
accepted with that you know it could
help me in life and make me feel good
about myself and all that [ __ ] I
thought it all comes down to how we feel
about her most people in Brooklyn and
come on brown surname we don't like
ourselves that's what we can't stay out
of prisons and stuff you know we believe
this is our destiny because that's what
we saw before us everybody all my best
friends are friends fathers and older
brothers and oldest friend she's going
in and out of jail and being celebrated
for it oh he's back [ __ ] back row and
then you back and that was brilliant
coming back that was just awesome you
came back from bring somebody especially
you did your time you know telling
nobody you're a man come back
I love you you're the man again hmm yeah
we thought that was dope yeah right yeah
you thought that was dope interesting
you know you want to be that guy yeah
but you come back home with no skills no
any nothing
yes prepared to go back in that
receiving system just come back home
with respect no nobody has the job for
you they have a gun for you to have a
bag of dope for you but they don't have
a job for you you fade this is gonna be
you wouldn't take care of your family
and wife you don't have to look over
your back no that's not happening
normally life expectancy for guys to
come out of prison and I'll go back to
jail is probably a year you just don't
know how to do anything well you know
how to do you know I don't know how to
get started right now right yeah I mean
how do you guys where do you go listen
how do we get listen real somebody from
the house the percentage of somebody
some [ __ ] guys gotta buy this guy's
clothes that's a famous guy what's the
percentage of somebody's gonna get me
say hey I'm in a facility a facility
anyway I lost a possible Jose hey man
you like to start boxing I think you got
times you can go somewhere what's the
part what's the [ __ ] possibility
that's gonna happen down I know it's
come from where we come what's that
possibily it's scary for action yeah
look at brown fibers it was it true that
I'm not really from that place I really
evolved from that place did I can't
believe it you know I said well how did
I make it out of there
these guys that got caught up in that
system that was a lot smarter than me
this guy I looked up to these guys was
smarter they they always got away they
would always they talked better they had
more education why they stayed and I got
out of that situation and it's just you
don't know that's when you say who are
we
is it definite for this to happen or
anything I was caring about it because
sometimes we get all these blessings and
we're still jerks and [ __ ] so it's
our consciousness our consciousness is
not why we here why am I so tired even
when I'm a dick when I should feel why
am I still succeeding maybe it's for
another purpose bigger than myself I
don't know I'm not saying I'm somebody
special
does that happen with anybody else stuff
that they feel there's no person you
just can't succeed and I do it enough
succeed
so you said yourself this is this is
weird and you don't want to look at
yourself a deep down inside you know who
you are you know your mistake since I
hate myself I'm nothing I'm a [ __ ] how
could I be anything but still great
things are happening for you so you get
discouraging you want to destroy it
that's you know I don't want to be this
guy no more people saying they love me I
knowing the way love me it's you got to
get adapted to that lifestyle again you
know all my life I was hurt there's
nothing [ __ ] never happened to me I
love you you're the greatest all this
[ __ ] that's scary stuff what do you
think about that Carl I think it's real
I think that um we all here for a
purpose
and you're right why me you know why me
out everybody that why did I think of it
first what I think about that is I
didn't think about it it just happened
you know it happened in the moment I
accepted each moment that came our way I
didn't fight against a moment like I
didn't know I wasn't do : I was trying
to other [ __ ] it just happened you know
just happened I made the alpha so I paid
the compliments my friends wanted to buy
some you know I didn't plan that that to
happen why that happening I made me make
them something and but I girl making a
comment it she didn't make that comment
that day I could have still just been
making plain clothes yeah you know
saying that comment that she made me go
home and think of a name and I started
that journey but I accepted each mom
just went with what was happening
I wanna come to California easy never
caught the case they never moved to
California he would never call my house
I didn't ever make cross colors none of
this [ __ ] would happen I still did fire
in Brooklyn making cold it you know
saying why me coming here cross colors
had financing behind and he's able to
finance Karl Kani from us working in
apartment doing maybe two three thousand
dollars a month to have another
warehouse 50,000 square foot warehouse
to finance millions of dollars worth the
orders he took a risk though you know
the chance to being hurt by these
[ __ ] maniacs back in the day and
stuff so you took a lot of risk it
wasn't like he didn't come and
just like all glory days right you know
right so so deep when you think about it
yeah well you know means deep cuz it
could've been anybody I think what you
said was just hit it on the head though
man
accepting each moment as it came to you
yeah except it's not a sudden rain right
yeah I got a deuce right [ __ ] up and
see where I go to prison and I could
this [ __ ] is just too good mmm
you know and I got just as much of power
of tearing myself down that I give my
bullet building myself up is such a
weird thing right it's interesting yeah
I think when I think about all this
conversation and I think the slight
difference that I had some of my friends
those my mother kept me in Baptist
Church and she kept me in Catholic
school but I still grew up in the hood
yeah dude I mean this is almost like you
got two worlds and five percent nation
as well
is that a lot of different information
one times you can see different things
and look at life slightly differently
than somebody else's parents weren't at
home daddy careful unboxing kept me
that's all I thought about I became a
fanatic because I'm one of those guys if
I get any information somebody say Mike
this is what we're doing now I want to
know who the first guy ever did it yeah
so I give the box the first guy I don't
even know how to act with the box what
the [ __ ] box act like I have to read
about great fighters and still find out
how they act Natalie conducted
themselves oh that's how I want to be I
want to be like this guy love this guy
[ __ ] box acts and no idea yeah that
makes sense to me well Carl what do you
have what's happening right now what do
you got going right now deaf kids yeah
got two of that uh my son's 22 my
daughter's 18 yeah well my daughter
throw her first she's 18 years old she's
a culinary chef yeah oh no she doing huh
oh she's my minute to me
she's focus when day one she she came to
me she's in a sixth grade she want to be
home school because she was focus on her
business and he mastered : every chef
and self-taught she does pop up she just
did a dinner for Smokey Robinson at his
house she catered
though she does a lot of smoke she
cooked flour she cooked for Oprah you
know Simone Dell Cool J's wife is her
aunt she makes dinners for them so she's
good my son he's 22
he just left University of Washington
had a baseball scholarship they're
Huskies yeah and playing baseball in
Sherman Oaks California all year-round
yeah he had the talent to go to the next
level but he didn't want the grind of
baseball anymore I think he got burnt
out at baseball so now he's doing
computing out of 3d animation and
building websites and that world right
there that's also that's kind of where
he's at with his life but the two great
kids love him to death
um inspire me every day to continue to
do what I do
I don't be a damn so I have my kids on
the raids in Brownsville mmm the earth
God my poor babies yeah reckoning [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] me felons problem my
gosh I may have bullets in them and
slices on their faith you asked me what
was next
yeah what do you got going right now man
yeah so right now we're celebrating our
30th University this year 30 years quark
and I started 89 so right now we have 10
stores in Japan and we distributed in 25
foreign countries Germany Switzerland
Amsterdam is party bringing some of our
biggest markets and Italy so we're doing
a 30th anniversary in Germany Cologne
Germany on this August so we gonna do
that and we just here just don't
penetrate in the streets again 90s
fashion is back so we back on track it's
awesome and I really want my own tracks
ooh there you go okay I'll [ __ ] buy
it dude I know it's like what seat belt
is made out of yeah that nylon yeah
still can still rock that on the pod
dude well thanks for coming man
absolutely this is awesome great to get
to know you and elephants
thank you Oh your brother again thank
you thank you thank you yeah Mel my
awesome job hey listen another great
episode of hot boxing the great
legendary seamstress designer called
canal is here and he leave it is
anything you want the people to know
y'all checked me out call can i without
a doubt
xxx University coming up check us out on
instagram call cannot Twitter all that
call kana peace out of here awesome
chelator FIBA there you go
[Music]